[Music]
well I guess many people were sort of
inventing the term at the time but I
remember kind of making it up you know
for me I hadn't heard it before when I
was finishing my first book the beauty
myth and it it was kind of an early
exercise in if you build it they will
come thinking because at the time I
wrote the beauty myth everyone was
saying feminism is dead no one's
interested it's over and in fact there
wasn't a lot of there was almost no
activity on the part of young women
especially and second way feminists were
you know their mom's age so I said at
the in book you know there's going to be
this third wave of feminism and I sort
was hoping well you know if I say it
maybe someone will join up you know of
course other people like Rebecca Walker
were also using the phrase at the same
time what's the definition you know I
don't think it really needs to have a
rigorous definition I've never been one
who's a fan of labels to me it just
means women who are younger
substantially younger than second wave
feminists you know does that generation
of third and probably now fourth wave
feminists have different a different
style in their feminism I think there's
some differences and they're good
differences I think third wave feminism
tends to be much more pluralistic about
sexuality and personal expression and
you know fashion choices and much less
dogmatic which i think is great I think
third wave feminism tends to be more
alert than some second wave feminists
were to issues of class and race I think
third wave feminists are more engaged
tend to be more engaged with being
willing to use power like to use the
media or to use the the electoral
process or to use consumer practices for
a good outcome which is great like
second wave feminism tended to be kind
of puritanical like we can only be
really good if we don't touch the
marketplace we don't touch the media we
don't touch you know politics as usual
but apart from that I mean what I love
about what I love about being kind of
superannuated you know I love being kind
of the dinosaurs and letting the young
ones kind of carry the ball forward
um I mean what I love about the third
wave in the fourth wave is it's time for
them to make their own mistakes you know
to create their own theories and you
know throw up their own leaders and
that's as it should be that means that a
movement is a long and vigorous
[Music]
I didn't write a piece in which I said
that Westerners should beware of being
presumptuous in assuming they know that
a hijab means oppression to a woman
wearing it and where did I get that from
I got it from feminists in the Muslim
world saying again and again things like
you know what we have much worse
problems than this you know it's much
more urgent that they're burning
you know Brides or that you know we're
facing force clitoridectomy likey
Westerners are so preoccupied with are
wearing a headscarf you know get a grip
this is you know like grow up and many
many feminists I've heard from including
young women in Western Europe and I
think it's very interesting and I was
just reporting what they said they said
very intriguingly to me as the author of
meeting of that when they were the
headscarf or modest clothing like a
hijab they chose to do so and these are
I'm talking about like the head of the
Oxford Union you know this beautiful
brilliant young Muslim woman who could
have worn anything she wanted and she
chose to wear a headscarf and she said
for her uh wearing a headscarf or more
modest clothing made her feel freer
in a Western context than wearing
western clothing freer of
objectification a freer of sexual
harassment freer of having to worry all
the time about how she looked compared
to fashion models and I thought that was
intriguing and I thought it was
intriguing to surface these comments
because I think you know we're in such
deep conflict with the Muslim world
right now we all know in the West and
one of the problems is our you know
their presumptions about what our
culture means and stereotypes about
Western corruption and our presumptions
about what their culture means the
stereotypes about Islam so I think it's
healthy for Westerners to turn a lens on
Western practices gee maybe you know
it's not necessarily so free to define
freedom in this very reductive way we do
in the West as you know any kind of
sexual expression any kind of purchasing
power any kind of you know secular
practice I mean there are other ways of
looking at
how other people see us and even if we
don't agree with those ways I do think
that it's a very important time to be
engaged in an open dialogue with his you
know with the Muslim world and be open
to hearing you know Muslim woman's own
interpretations of what the hijab means
for them are there many other Muslim
women who think it's very oppressive
absolutely and I remember saying the
piece that that is true of course
[Music]